the Supreme Court gives the go-ahead to
sleeping on the streets Democrats have
the votes for impeachment and Rudy
claims he's got the goods on Joe and
Hunter Biden i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show avenger Piro show is
sponsored by expressvpn stand up for
your digital rights visit expressvpn
dot-com slash men we're gonna get to
everything impeachment related
momentarily as I've been saying now for
weeks this is all a foregone conclusion
nothing really new is happening this is
all just a dog and pony show at this
point but there are some wrinkles to the
dog and pony show we'll bring those to
you momentarily in a much bigger issue
that will have more long lasting
ramifications for Americans than this
impeachment debacle cuz the impeachment
is gonna move forward Democrats won't
peach in the House Republicans will
acquit in the Senate will move forward
to 2020 and whoever wins will win and
whoever loses will lose that's the way
this is going to work a far bigger issue
is the fact that America's major cities
are now collapsing in on themselves like
dying stars America's major cities are
becoming worse and worse in terms of
living standards for the people who live
there and that's not true for every city
but it's certainly true for cities like
Los Angeles where I live I'm old enough
to remember when Los Angeles where I've
lived nearly my entire life with the
exception of three years in
Massachusetts when I was in law school
everyone it has gone from a very
liveable nice city particularly in the
suburbs to an incredibly dirty city
where there are insane amounts of litter
trash on the streets open needles in
suburban areas and near schools
we got homeless people on nearly every
corner there is not an embankment in Los
Angeles that is not occupied by homeless
people all over the all over the city
and that is because major cities around
the United States have refused to do
what is necessary in arresting people
and ensuring that they actually have a
place to go with regard to not just
housing but in terms of mental illness
in terms of drug abuse one of the
obvious facts about homelessness in
major cities that is largely driven by
mental illness severe mental illness and
drug abuse and alcohol abuse and that
means that you have to approach this
thing with a both a carrot and a stick
so what the left would like to do is
approach this thing with just the care
and say okay well here is some housing
here's some housing that we've built for
you and we've seen this in Los Angeles
where it's costing like half a million
dollars to build a unit of housing
thanks to building regulations because
the government is insane and that means
that
cost you more to house somebody for a
year than to do pretty much anything
else with them in the state of
California and in the city of Los
Angeles you've seen this approach taken
also in Seattle where they've set up
what they literally start it's called
drunk dorms where there are no
restrictions and who can live in these
areas and as it turns out a lot of
homeless people don't actually want to
live under the same roof with a bunch of
other people who may in fact be violent
alcoholics so that's been a serious
problem you have to combine this with a
stick approach yes you have to have the
carrot of a place for people to go but
you also have to have the stick approach
which is if you violate the law we will
send you to jail and if you keep
violating the law we'll keep sending you
to jail and also if we want paranoid
schizophrenic off the streets they will
require some mandatory treatment and
that does not mean that you that you get
to simply walk out of the treatment
facility when you feel like you are
cured and then go right back to the
streets where you are not taking your
proper medication this comes as somebody
from somebody who has my grandfather was
a schizophrenic his life was saved by
the fact that he was taking medication
at a mental facility he was actually put
away in a mental facility for like a
year and eight months a year and it
saved his life he would you have to have
the legal ability to take people who
cannot care for themselves and put them
in a position where they receive the
care that they need and the whole point
of severe mental illnesses that you are
unable to control yourself the same
thing is true of severe drug addiction
if you cannot arrest people for living
on the street and then put them in
mandatory drug rehab it's gonna be very
difficult to ever move them off the
street and the housing only approach has
failed pretty much everywhere that it's
tried the only place where it supposedly
succeeded with Salt Lake City and that
turned into such a money pit that Salt
Lake City had to cut its own
expenditures on housing also it happens
that Salt Lake City is supported in huge
in huge amounts by the social fabric of
the Mormon Church which is there provide
all sorts of social support for people
who are homeless provides all sorts of
services there
those sorts of services don't exist in
major cities around the country when
government does provide those sorts of
social services it actually acts as a
magnet for homelessness and in fact even
in Salt Lake City after a 91 percent
decrease in homelessness over a decade
they saw for two straight years each
year a doubling of the homeless
population after
became widely publicized that they were
giving away all sorts of goodies to
homeless people because as it turns out
that is an incentive structure well part
of the issue here has to be part of the
solution has to be the threat of law
enforcement taking your stuff arresting
you putting you in into mandatory drug
rehabilitation placing you into a mental
facility mental health facility where
you receive mandatory drugs that will
that will help care for your severe
mental illness all of these things need
to be on the table none of them are on
the table and now the Supreme Court has
turned down the appeal of an insane
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals ruling
that suggests that it is a violation of
the Eighth Amendment of the United
States Constitution to find people for
living out in public on the streets
really this is what the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals found the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals a few months ago found
that it was a violation of the cruel and
unusual punishment Clause of the
Constitution of the United States to
give people a $25 ticket force for
living on a sidewalk which is pure
insanity by the way you want to destroy
a city this is the way you do it not
just because the living conditions go
down but also because you destroy the
ability of businesses to do business in
the city of Los Angeles have many many
friends who are police officers in the
city of Los Angeles and one of the big
problems is that a business owner will
call them up and say I've got a homeless
person who is sitting on my stoop and
peeing right in front of the business
and my customers can't get in and the
police officers will say well is the
person trying to break in I'll say no so
well there's not we can't do anything
about that they're just living right
there there's nothing they can do about
that because the city of Los Angeles has
decided to go along with all of this
nonsense this has some predictable
effects in terms of how cities are run
and how Dorothy I we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that rights in America are the
basis of our Constitution and protection
of Rights is the basis of our
Constitution and yes we relied on a
limited government to protect our rights
but the final repository of your rights
is in you it's in the people and that is
particularly true for the right to
self-defense this is why I'm a big
believer in the Second Amendment and so
are the folks over at USC CA listen up
because this is your last chance to win
a thousand bucks from my friends at the
USC CA after this this offer is gone
right now the USC C is giving away a
thousand bucks to 19 lucky winners this
holiday season just for texting in you
text the word win that's WI n 2
seven two two two and can claim your
free chances to get a thousand dollars
it's really that simple but you need to
hurry because this is the last giveaway
the US ECA is offering this year it ends
this Friday December 20th don't miss
your chance to get a thousand bucks from
the US see see a text win 287 - 2 - it's
important that Second Amendment
supporters practice their support of the
Second Amendment by being responsible
gun owners the u.s. CCA believes that
they provide you all sorts of
educational and legal resources us CCA
is proud to provide life-saving
education training and legal protection
to over three hundred thousand
law-abiding Americans every year you
should join up to text win 287 - - - for
your final chance to win a thousand
bucks 100% secure it takes only seconds
text win the word win wi n 287 - - to
win 287 - 2 - so now the Supreme Court
has ruled again that you have a right to
sleep on the streets they did so not by
ruling that out right but by refusing to
overrule this 9th Circuit Court of
Appeals ruling now this has some
predictable effects so for example in
San Francisco this picture was going
around yesterday it is a picture of a
homeless man who was being described by
other people in the wrote this is taken
by a journalist the journalist said this
person was clearly a drug addict
this person literally went into a
supermarket in San Francisco and
proceeded to defecate on the floor the
good news is that they found the toilet
paper aisle so at least they have the
toilet paper to deal with it the bad
news is there was an open bathroom with
no one occupying it in the same store
and this person just decided to go poop
right on the floor of the supermarket
and this has become San Francisco I had
a colleague
Cassie Dylan she went over to San
Francisco and took tape on took video
tape of all of the street corners in San
Francisco and San Francisco has become a
feces fest the entire city has turned
into a trash heap it's one of those
beautiful cities in America the same
thing has happened in Seattle where a
gem of a city I used to do a local show
up in Seattle a gem of a city has been
turned into a homeless encampment and
the past several mayor's have refused to
do anything about it
citing the right to live on the streets
well I shouldn't say they're doing
nothing about it over in Seattle
Seattle's homeless agency actually hired
a transgender performer named Beyonce
black st. James - they're all home
conference in South Seattle for a group
of homeless advocates this person is a
transgender stripper which is a look and
they spent money
on this to fight homelessness
homelessness cured guys they fixed
homelessness all it took was finding a
trans Jamin who believes that his woman
has had some surgeries to prove it
all it takes is a transgender female
stripper parading around and twerking at
a homeless conference on taxpayer dime
to fix this thing Oh oh god no we cut
this tape so that you didn't actually
have to oh no okay we're gonna not do
that guys okay let's just stop it and
let's get that off the screen there's no
one on stop it stop it stop enough nope
nope nope you don't do not subject the
American people to that well the good
news is the American people paid for
that the Seattle taxpayers paid for that
according to our friend Jason ranch over
at Katie th Seattle's homelessness
crisis shows no signs of subsiding
meanwhile an agency tasked with tackling
the issue spent taxpayer dollars on a
strip show
transgender performer Beyonce black st.
James stripped at the all home
conference in South Seattle for a group
of homeless advocates all home is the
King County agency that coordinates the
services for the homeless the conference
theme was decolonizing our collective
work what the what does that mean
decolonizing
our collective work is your collective
work colonized by what like strap-like
what it wasn't clear to attendees that
the organization had planned a strip
show for the conference according to the
seattle times the agenda simply
explained participants would attend a
lunch with cultural presentation that is
one cultural presentation is a
transgender woman lip-synching and
stripping revealing silver silver nipple
coverings and a bodysuit some
participants handed her dollar bills
others looked clearly uncomfortable at
one point st. James appeared to place
his breasts on a participants head at
another he rubbed his backside up
against a woman in a chair and then
caressed the leg and chest of a man st.
James would later use them use map his
mouth to take a dollar bill out of this
other person's mouth and then of course
some twerking the transgender stripper
by the way is not the person to blame as
Jason Rance points out this person's
name is Kiera Zylstra the administrator
who was earning a hundred and
twenty-three thousand dollars a year to
fight homelessness
yes public service pays well the person
ended up resigning but not but how much
do government's waste on nonsense like
this the answer is
not a little money and so the Supreme
Court has declared by refusing to rule
on this Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals
ruling that there is no right to sleep
on the streets a right to sleep on the
streets the ruling by the Ninth Circuit
is insane it said that a city ordinance
violates the Eighth Amendment cruel and
unusual punishment right it's a it's
like using the rack on somebody to write
them a 25 dollar tickets if they don't
move their crap from out in front of a
business it violates the Eighth
Amendment insofar as it imposes criminal
sanctions against homeless individuals
for sleeping outdoors on public property
when no alternative shelter is available
to them so you've seen these kinds of
Court rulings I mean this is judicial
supremacy at its finest judicial
supremacy is when the judiciary simply
usurps the role of legislators and this
is what has been going on in terms of
for example Union states you will see
the judiciary simply say that the state
must sign a contract with the unions
that meet the following criteria you've
seen this with regard to some states on
education some states will say you know
the the state the state constitution
suggests that you have to properly fund
education properly fund means you have
to spend X percentage of the budget on
education okay that is the judiciary now
playing the legislature well this is
what the judiciary here is doing to say
when no alternative shelter is available
to them you can't write somebody a
ticket means that basically the Ninth
Circuit is saying it's your brains or
your signature on this piece of paper
either you have to let these people
sleep on the street and defecate on the
street because that is one of the things
that goes along with sleeping on the
streets as it turns out you have to let
them destroy the safety and and security
of a city unless you build them the kind
of shelter we believe is appropriate
that is blackmailing the taxpayers from
the judicial branch has that electoral
politics that's not even democracy
that's the judiciary deciding what it
thinks is best policy without having any
responsibility for implementing that
policy even Los Angeles County was like
what is this stuff
Los Angeles County Supervisor mark
ridley-thomas who is no right winger he
said that they had they had joined the
lawsuit against these homeless advocacy
organizations he said that that they
were looking for a a clear framework a
legal framework in comparison to the
status quo that is ambiguous and
confusing he said letting the current
law stand handicap cities and counties
from acting nimbly to aid those
perishing on the streets exacerbating
safe in unhealthy conditions that
negatively affect our most vulnerable
residents la mayor Eric Garcetti who is
just awful he said in a statement that
quote homelessness won't be solved by
moving people from one street to another
our focus will remain on providing
services to save lives keep on keeping
our neighborhoods clean and healthy
opening shelters to help get people
indoors more quickly and building
permanent units to keep them under a
roof for good none of those things have
happened in LA I live here I can testify
none of those things have happened in LA
LA is one giant homeless encampment
there over 60,000 homeless people living
in this in the county of Los Angeles and
now these and now the Supreme Court has
allowed the Ninth Circuit to cram down
its own vision of how to fight
homelessness on every other major city
and that does not include the ability to
even rouse people move their stuff and
what that this means mass homelessness
is going to continue to be the rule not
the exception when it comes to America's
major cities thanks to the judiciary
well done everybody just excellent
excellent job making America's Joules
unlivable okay in just a second we're
gonna get to the latest on imbues from
engaged 2019 first let's talk about a
fantastic fantastic gift for the
holidays how do I know this advance has
to get because let me tell you my wife
is basically a saint I mean she's
married to me why would she stay married
to you you ask well the answer I get her
really nice jewelry from the pearl
source the pearl source okay Christmas
and Hanukkah are next week but here is
the thing it is not too late the pearl
source offers free two-day shipping on
every order everything comes beautifully
packaged into elegant jewelry box so
it's ready to be given as a gift you'll
receive those beautiful pearls in time
for the holidays my wife has a beautiful
pearl necklace from the Pearl source.com
/ Ben she also has a pair of earrings
that are just gorgeous they're these
kind of diamond dripping hearings into a
giant pearl it's it's just beautiful
beautiful stuff all their jewelry is
beautiful and here's the thing it's up
to 70% off retail prices because they
are skipping the traditional five times
markup by skipping the middleman and if
you're not sure if you love the gift
don't worry the Pearl source comes with
a no hassle 60-day money-back guarantees
that's risk-free so you buy her a piece
of jewelry which I promise you she'll
love and she's like no I don't like that
one I like this haven't one you can just
go to the pearl source and you're good
plus with more than 20 years in the
pearl business over five thousand five
star reviews you can be sure you're
shopping from a trusted retailer by the
way you can also ensure you're shopping
from a trusted retail because I know
these people I'm very very good friends
with the people who run the pearl source
and I can tell you they are
extraordinarily honest great family
folks you're helping out a family
business it really is a it's a
spectacular business and their product
is beautiful and it is going to last
forever because it's beautiful beautiful
jewelry for a limited time listeners to
my show take an additional 20% off your
entire order go to the Pearl source comm
slash pen enter promo code Bennett check
out for 20% off your entire order if you
want fine jewelry at the best prices
online go straight to the source the
Pearl source again that's pearls the
Pearl source calm / pen enter promo code
Ben at checkout
okay so meanwhile on impeachments this
is the week this is the week because
Democrats are going to lay out the case
for a Wednesday Trump impeachment vote
according to the Associated Press so
tomorrow the historic Jay when Democrats
declare our impeachment the reason by
the way they're doing it on Wednesday is
because Thursday is the next big
Democratic presidential debate and so
they don't want to detract from
attention on debate day so they're gonna
do impeachment on Wednesday and then the
Democrats can spend the first half of
the debate on Thursday talking about how
much they hate president Trump but don't
worry this isn't political at all it's
not political it's just they love the
Constitution so so so much that's all
according to the AP House Democrats laid
out their impeachment case against
President Trump on Monday a sweeping
report accusing him of betraying the
nation and deserving to be ousted as key
lawmakers began to signal where they
scan ahead of this week's landmark votes
what Democrats once hoped would be a
bipartisan Act only the third time in US
history the house will be voting to
impeach a president has now on track to
be a starkly partisan roll call on
Wednesday no Republicans are breaking
with the president almost all Democrats
are expected to approve the charges
against him a raucous Town Hall Monday
in the Detroit suburbs put on display
the nation's wrenching debate over the
unconventional president and the
prospect of removing him from office
freshman Democratic Representative at
Lisa slot Ken was both heckled and
celebrated as she announced her support
for impeachment she said there's
certainly a lot of controversy about
this but there just has to be a moment
where you use the letter of the law for
what it's intended because what was
intended was definitely charging a
president with no crimes and giving him
very very vague charges of abuse of
power and one that makes no sense
obstruction of Congress because again
there is no obstruction of Congress okay
obstruction of Congress has to be
connected with obstruction of justice
it is not obstruction of Congress for
the executive branch to refuse to comply
with subpoenas and then appeal to the
judicial branch to back them up
according to the 650 page report from
the House Judiciary Committee which I've
read some of it I gotta tell you it
feels like that that report feels like
back when you were in middle school and
your teacher was like I need a five
paragraph essay and so one of your
paragraphs and it needs to be 450 words
and so your essay said things like it
was a very very very very very very very
very very very very good time
boom 25 words right that's that report
there ain't enough there to support 650
pages of reading the president betrayed
the nation by abusing his high office to
enlist a foreign power in corrupting
democratic elections says the 650 page
report from the House Judiciary
Committee Trump has been tweeting and he
insisted he has done nothing wrong
he's also promoting Rudy Giuliani's
investigation of Jo and hunter Biden he
said of Rudy Giuliani he knows what he
is doing through Rudy Giuliani for his
part is going around the media saying
that he has uncovered money laundering
in Ukraine and if he's got the goods now
would be an excellent time to spill them
I mean Rudy like anytime now dude the
people that he's quoting by the way in
most of his reports are prosecutors who
have been widely derided for their
possible corruption and who appeared to
have conflicting motivations so I don't
take everything that Rudy Giuliani is
saying at face le I think there is
reason to be suspicious of how hunter
Biden ends it up in a position being
paid $50,000 a month when he was
competent to not hold a job like that
that is quite suspicious and there's no
question he was using daddy's name the
question is whether Jo knew about it or
what Joe was doing about it
there's certainly the empiricism
propriety but that doesn't mean that Joe
Biden was actually facilitating this or
getting people fired in order to back up
his son or anything like that with that
said if Rudy's got some hard evidence
and the hard evidence goes beyond here
are a couple of Ukrainian prosecutors
have stood for corruption talking about
it I'm willing to hear it here was Rudy
on Laura Ingraham show last night
talking about it I uncovered their yeah
are two major schemes one for 7.5
billion the other for 5 billion in money
laundering that went on all through the
Obama administration part of it involves
Joe Biden the bribery part it's a
disgrace that he's not under
investigation for it in America maybe
because
or enforcement is to afraid but the
reality is it's a complete defense for
the president okay so the idea here is
then if there was corruption in Ukraine
and Trump was interest in it then that
is a complete defense for the president
okay the fact is that a front put
suspicious of corruption in Ukraine and
he was asking about it that's a defense
of the president because it so long as
this is about corruption in Ukraine or
corruption in 2016 and not about going
after Joe Biden for 2020 then he has a
defense to the charges and Democrats
have not been able to establish the
requisite level of intent for bribery
which of course is why it is not
included in any of the impeachment
charges does that mean that Rudy
Giuliani has to prove his case in order
for Trump to get off on impeachment no
it doesn't actually so the Democrats
gonna move this thing forward on
Wednesday they're they're on the fence
members are now backing impeachment
because party loyalty is extraordinarily
solid at this point in time for both
Republicans and Democrats are not seeing
any crossover votes at this point it's
gonna hurt those Democrats in the swing
districts far more than it hurts the
Republicans there very few Republicans
who are existing in blue districts at
this point those blue districts purple
districts have basically been wiped out
for Republicans unfortunately that means
there are a lot of Democrats that are
sitting in Trump districts a lot of them
are going to lose their seats over this
according to The Wall Street Journal
more Democrats from competitive House
districts said they will back the
impeachment of President Trump putting
the effort on track to pass this week
despite some fear as their position
could put their seats at risk a
representative Joe Cunningham of South
Carolina said he would support
impeachment he said if I wanted to do
what was easy politically I would just
vote no and move on well actually no
there is no easy answer for some of
these Democrats existing in purple
districts two Democrats have said that
are opposed including one representative
Jeff manager of New Jersey who said he's
actually gonna switch parties
representative Colin Peterson of
Minnesota said he will vote against
impeachment as well bottom line is this
thing in the end is not really going to
go anywhere and everybody knows it now
that there was that this sort of funny
tete-a-tete between Chuck Schumer and
reporter yes sir so Chuck Schumer
appeared in front of the press and he
was explaining that he is very angry
that the Senate procedures aren't going
to be fulsome and allow the Democrats to
explain their case well they do control
the house they could have contain
Republicans should call all of these
witnesses from the executive branch well
I won't Republicans do this and a
reporter says to
um your house colleagues were supposed
to call those witnesses so why didn't
they and could have just waited for the
judiciary to sound off on the subpoenas
and they could have called all these
people and Schumer has no good answer
because there is no that answer well
look I'm not gonna second-guess the
house there is virtually no argument no
good argument if you're interested in
the facts and not having these witnesses
come forward now and remember the
standard at a trial is different than
the standard when a prosecutor in this
case the house impeachment Authority
puts together a case a trial is a place
for witnesses Oh a trial is a place for
witnesses as opposed to a House
Judiciary Committee hearing which is
also a place for witnesses and the House
Intelligence Committee hearing which was
also a place for witnesses he's gotten a
good answer on this because the real
answer Democrats to know they're not
gonna get what they want from these
witnesses and now we're all gonna
pretend and the media are gonna pretend
that because Mitch McConnell won't call
Mick Mulvaney that's the real reason why
this impeachment effort isn't moving
forward sure sure
by the way are these impeachment moves
actually hurting Trump the national
political polls do not suggest such a
thing there's a new Suffolk University
USA Today poll it is out today here is
what it finds in these our general
election numbers now general election
numbers I'm going to give you those
general election numbers in just one
second this stuff is not helping the
Democrats I'll get to it in just a
moment first let me tell you how much I
love steak steak is spectacular steak is
fantastic I love say it is wonderful and
did I not keep kosher
there is one deal I'd be taking
advantage of this holiday season and
that is a deal from Omaha Steaks I'm
talking about their favorite gift
package and this thing is so good it
makes me seriously consider kashrut the
favorite gift package from Omaha Steaks
calm you enter the code Shapiro in the
search bar and you can order it it's the
gift all your friends and family will
love for just $69.99 here is what you
get for six ound bacon-wrapped filet
mignons for premium pork chops for Omaha
Steaks burgers for potatoes au gratin
for caramel apple tartlets in Omaha
Steaks a signature seasoning packet
plus just for my listeners a free six
piece cutlery set and cutting boards you
get all those things for $69.99 how
great would that be to get for Christmas
Omaha Steaks are the most tender the
most flavorful only you can get steaks
of this quality from Omaha Steaks
America's original butcher again you get
that favorite gift package here's how
you do it you know Omaha Steaks calm you
type Shapiro's in the search bar and get
that favorite gift package plus be free
six piece cutlery set and cutting board
just $69.99 basically you're sending
you're sending a friend Christmas dinner
like the whole thing and also much more
than X that's a lot of food plus the
knives I mean that's it that's an
awesome deal Omaha Steaks calm types
capiro in the search bar add is a gift
that everybody is gonna love okay so
here is what the national polls are now
saying this is very bad for Democrats
it's bad news for Democrats according to
Suffolk University USA Today President
Trump in head-to-head matchups against
Democrats now leads Joe Biden 44 to 41
leads Bernie Sanders 44 to 39 leads
Elizabeth Warren 45 to 37 leads Michael
Bloomberg 43 to 34 and leads peabody
judge 43 to 33 so unless you believe
that all of the outlying votes are going
to go to the democrats that the you know
15 or 20% that are left over in those
polls aren't all going to swing to the
Democrat that's real bad news for the
Democrats right there now it is true
that Trump has stuck at 43 44 45 he was
for the entirety of the 2016 elections
who and he ended up at 46 so the fact is
that the President of the United States
is not in bad reelection territory
despite or maybe because of impeachment
that's not the only poll trending in
this direction hey there's an investor
business daily TI PP poll that just came
out this morning and here's what that
one found it shows the only Democrat
beating Biden beating Trump right now is
Biden it's got Biden at 50 and Trump at
the others have Biden up Trump up 48 47
over Sanders 47 46 over Bloomberg 46:44
over boo to judge and 4944 over Warren
Warren not showing strong in these
particular polls
according to according to that poll the
IBD GIP people that's a five-point shift
toward Trump versus Biden in the last
month a 13-point shift towards Trump
versus Warren in the last month and an
eighth
point shift towards from versus Sanders
these are horrible numbers for the
Democrats and part of that is
everybody's irritation with this
impeachment stuff part of this is the
fact that the economy is going well part
of this is the fact that Trump has made
some moves to solidify his re-election
here and he's moving to get the China
trade issue off the table he is moving
to get NAFTA 2.0 off the table he is
signing huge budget-busting numbered
budgets but at least he's getting it off
the table he's doing a lot of the things
that would be necessary in order to win
reelection
he looks a lot stronger today than he
did even six months ago this impeachment
effort is not going well for the
Democrats and the Democrats are starting
to realize it shoddy Hameed is a senior
fellow of Brookings Institution he has a
piece today called impeachment could end
badly he says I don't have the courage
of my conviction president Donald Trump
deserves to be impeached for trying to
pressure Ukraine to investigate his
political opponents with every week he
says or does something worse than what
he already said or did but to say Trump
deserves impeachment is different from
saying that impeachment is good for the
country in fact it might turn out quite
badly most of the people who might like
to trust or believe or believe rather
strongly that President Trump has done
rise what Trump has done rises to a
crime for them the analysis of whether
from should be impeached can't help but
be informed by their view that Trump
represents an existential threat to the
country yet if you do believe as I do
the Trump is bad but also that is
badness falls somewhat short of an
existential threat an impeachment
however justified in theory becomes less
straightforward the process does not
unfold in a political vacuum Democrats
should not let the certainty of their
legal reasoning push them toward
impeachment without regard for its
real-world consequences which are
uncertain and could prove costly now
even this narrative is suggestive of the
idea the Democrats are just pursuing
Trump for impeachment because they feel
the constitutional necessity to do so
that there was no political calculation
that went into it no what happened here
is that Nancy Pelosi made a political
calculation a few months back her
political calculation was quite simple
it was what are the cost and what are
the benefits of impeaching Trump the
cost of impeaching Trump would be maybe
some blowback but most people don't like
Trump the benefits of impeaching Trump
if more evidence came forward would be
that he is made more unpopular drives
him down for 2020 or it Out's him
completely
finishing Republican hopes for 2020 that
was her calculation but there is one
problem with her calculation
and that is the American people really
really are not into this impeachment
charade and there has been a backlash to
it that it appears to be political and
that Trump has mobilized his forces
pretty well here to defend himself the
fact is that this is back lashing on the
Democrats it is bad news for the
Democrats and so they are relegated to
relying on their base which is not where
they want it to be in an impeachment
move
they are relegated to relying on the on
the strong blue sentiments of people
like Michelle Goldberg the opinion
columnist for The New York Times who has
a piece today titled on Tuesday March
for impeachment the anti-trump majority
needs to make itself seen yes I'm sure
Marsh will do it I am sure that that a
big marsh like the women's March they'll
probably or maybe the March for our
lives a big marches on hot-button
political issues have definitely
achieved what they sought to achieve in
precisely zero percent of cases over the
last 10-15 years I'm sure that's gonna
go really really well for you she says
demonstrations aren't a bet aren't just
about pressuring Republicans
despite cable and social media local TV
news is still many people's primary news
source because they're going to be
demonstrations everywhere their eight
plan for Montana alone local TV will
likely cover them and therefore there is
going to be an upsurge in impeachment
heavy opinion yeah sure sure I'm sure
and just a second we will get to the
other PR efforts by the pro-impeachment
forces in just one second they are not
good and they're not good because I
think everybody understands the
underlying animus that so many people
hold for Trump and for Trump supporters
because that really is not even Trump
supporters conservatives generally what
the media do not understand is that
every poll on Trump is not actually a
poll on Trump it is a poll on what
people think the media think of them
every poll about whether you like Trump
or not is not a poll of whether you like
Trump when you ask a conservative or a
Republican do you like Trump and you get
a call from one of these posters most
Republicans are thinking do I like you
it's a pull on the pollsters they don't
trust you they don't trust the left to
make these decisions there is no solid
unity that suggests that people you
disagree with are acting in the name of
the Constitution because nobody actually
believes that I'll show you in just one
second first let's talk about the watch
you're wearing so I'm a watch guy
I love watches I'm very into watches
I've got some really nice expensive
watches and then I've got watches that
don't break the bank but our
spectacularly good-looking I fir their
price point they're just unbelievable
and Here I am talking about Vin cheral
watches okay this watch right here this
is this beautiful whoa look at this
chronograph this is a really nice
chronograph and the mechanism is really
great
it moves beautifully okay this this VIN
chair Oh watch which is really nice is
certainly not going to cost you a
fortune they really you know luxury
watch will cost you thousands and
thousands of dollars you can get a
really nice great-looking watch for
hundreds of dollars instead at VIN chair
oh they make modern watches that look
good last the lifetime and don't cost a
fortune then Cheryl was nice enough to
send me and my wife some of their
watches they're fantastic quality again
these are great watches I would not have
expected this nice we'll watch at this
price point please head on over to then
Cheryl watches comm /jh apparel and C my
favorite picks my wife loves her friend
Cheryl watch I also got some for like I
went out I should got some for my sister
for her birthday my mom hasn't been
Cheryl watch now they're just terrific
watches don't forget to use code shapiro
a check out for 15% off your entire
order also you can you can engrave the
back of the watch so you can actually
make it a commemorative edition facts
don't care about your feelings wash or
you know you're commemorating some dates
with your with your family you can
actually just engrave the back of it it
really is a cool feature then chero
believes watches can do more than tell
time they tell the world what you're all
about they've got sporty watches
they've got nice-looking evening watches
they got automatics they've got courts
and that all sorts of great stuff this
deal is fantastic go to vin Cheryl
watches comm /up hero that's VI n C ero
watches comm /up hero then Cheryl
watches comm /up hero use code Shapiro
to get 15% off Finch arrow watches comm
VI n c ER o watches that come forward
slash Shapiro and use that promo code
Shapiro 15% off okay more on why this
thing is not going well for Democrats
and why the country is too polarized for
any impeachment effort really to go
particularly well for the Democrats but
first exciting news game we are now
hiring as one of the biggest companies
in conservative media daily wire is
growing fast looking for talented people
to join our team go check out open
positions over at Daley wire.com slash
careers apply today applicants must be
LA based or willing to relocate if
you're looking for an awesome company
culture full of amazing people to work
with
well I'll pretend this
the place to be if you'd like to be
featured in a zip recruiter ad this is
definitely the place to be that's daily
wire.com slash careers go apply now and
join us also we have the perfect gift
for you to give this holiday season it
is the gift of a Daily wire membership
from now until January 1st all insider
plus gift memberships will be 25% off
that means your loved one will get all
the fantastic perks plus the majestic
leftist here's some blur and you will
receive the savings if you're not
already a subscriber you're really
missing out head on over to daily
wire.com and subscribe again that is 25%
off all insider plus gift memberships
this holiday season give them a gift
they will thank you for all year long
head on over to Taylor wire.com / gift
and get that 25% off again
that's daily wire.com / gift to get 25%
off do not wait stop depriving yourself
come join the fun we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
you
okay so looking at the the PR attempts
to mobilize support behind this
impeachment effort the fact is the
reason you're not going to get PR
support is because the people who are
behind the impeachment effort are widely
perceived to be partisan hacks because
they are Adam Schiff is a partisan hack
Jerry Nadler is a partisan hack and the
people in the media who are pushing this
thing appear to be partisan hacks
that's why moments that are seemingly
unrelated to impeachment actually do
have an impact on how people think about
this stuff so for example on the view
yesterday now remember Barack Obama said
just yesterday that if women ran
everything in politics then the world
would be a nicer better place the view
stands is a ringing endorsement of the
opposite idea because let me tell you
that place it ain't good for the case
that lady's running the world is gonna
go fantastic that just because of their
X chromosomes things are gonna go really
really great so Meghan McCain who is not
a Trumpster okay go and look at our
Sunday special I interviewed Meghan for
an hour she she and I are friends she is
not a fan of Trump at all I mean and and
honestly like I get it
Trump has spent half his career ripping
the crap out of John McCain even after
his death so I I totally got it Megan
McCain who is not a Trump defender is on
the view and she's explaining why
impeachment politically is going bad for
Democrats or at least she is trying to
but doesn't go well because Whoopi
Goldberg isn't having any of it it is
moments like this that make people go
you know what Trump forever Megan
doesn't even support Trump okay but
makes people go Trump forever why as a
giant pulsating middle finger to people
like Whoopi Goldberg because watch out
Whoopi Goldberg treats Megan McCain here
look at the sisterhood and we keep
hearing about female solidarity yeah man
the sisterhood and Whoopi Goldberg
treats Megan McCain like trash here she
really does she treats her like garbage
and she'll get no blowback for
management over at ABC because that's
not the way this works only people who
apparently make the grave mistake of
announcing that ABC has quashed
investigations into Jeffrey Epstein get
treated like garbage over there and the
and the token conservative on the view
so here's Megan McCain trying to explain
she's not even saying I'm anti
impeachment she's just saying
impeachment is not gonna work out well
for Democrats and Whoopi Goldberg loses
her bleep honor she flips her flips her
wig over it it's crazy girl please stop
talking please stop talking right now
cuz you know what know what's happening
thank thank you I want to hug this out
okay
that's I'm okay with that I'm okay with
that if you're gonna behave like this
yes we are no I am that you are with
what you're doing no I'm not you're us
we're not doing anything how about this
former FBI we'll be right back okay and
then she goes to break because Whoopi
Goldberg and first of all putting Whoopi
Goldberg in charge of that show is such
a joke on its face but beyond that
Whoopi Goldberg going after Meghan
McCain for simply trying to say that
impeachment is a bad political idea shut
up girl which is basically what she's
saying first well of any dude ever said
that to any woman on national television
they lose their job right if any man
said to any woman stop talking right now
it's most sexist patriarchal thing ever
Whoopi Goldberg those intersectional
Meghan McCain is not Whoopi Goldberg is
on the Left Meghan McCain is not there
for Whoopi Goldberg can say girls stop
talking right now by the way if Meghan
McCain said that to what P Goldberg
should probably be fired the next day
that's the way this works and it's that
dynamic that leads people to go middle
finger man leads them to say Trump all
the way because if Trump is just a way
to rebut that kind of garbage if Trump
is basically a giant fu to that entire
class of people and I mean the the
hardcore left that wants to silence
debate and find Trump impeachment is
more about that than it is about what's
in the impeachment report just like
elections are more about that than they
are about differential ideas on Medicare
for all elections are far more in
today's day and age about the feeling
that people have about one another in
the United States the feeling they have
about the media in the United States
this is Trump knows this right Trump has
an innate gut feel for this it's why he
won the election last time it's why he's
in good shape this time yes he's gonna
have to tout his accomplishments yes he
should let the accomplishment speak
firms for themselves and I am the person
who's been saying for years and he needs
to tone down the tweeting but I have
never said you should tone down the
tweeting when it comes to him ripping
the media I think he should be accurate
about it I don't think I should call
everything fake news when it's not but
him going after members of the left and
pointing out that this is a that this is
a culture this is a cultural battle is
not wrong people elected him for this
and people are the more you get a
Whoopie this is how you got trumpet
you're gonna get more Trump this way
you're gonna get more Trump when you
bring Robert DeNiro on the view to
explain that Donald Trump is worse
than any character he has ever played
including Travis Bickel who's a person
who is planning to murder a politician
or I guess then his characters in a wide
variety of films who are gangsters who
shoot people in the face here's Rob
first of all why Robert De Niro's a
political authority on anything is
absolutely beyond me
the man is an actor he has no political
expertise on anything Ronald Reagan
spent years talking about politics and
economics for GE before he was elected
governor of California Robert DeNiro has
spent years playing the same role since
Godfather three sometimes for comedic
effect and sometimes for non comedic
effect here is Robert De Niro explaining
incoherently the Donald Trump is worse
than traffic Travis Bickle a
psychopathic murderer you have played
some of the most really unredeemable
characters a psychopathic taxi driver
Jake LaMotta whose to beat his wife and
he was in the Raging Bull is Trump worse
than they are to me is because he has no
understanding that I can see of the
outside world other than anything around
him he has no idea of what his purpose
in life is as the president should be
and that is to pull the country together
to be for the people to heal wounds not
to open them up and pour salt on me he's
he's a low-life our moral leader Robert
De Niro and then Robert De Niro in an
attempt to really heal the nation and
close those wounds he says that if his
family meaning like Ivanka and and Jared
and Eric and Donald Trump jr. if his
family were like the Trump family he
would disown them this is him healing
the wounds of the nation Robert De Niro
perfect example of a man healing the
wounds of the nation he'll also talk
about his children and you say that
they're like a gangster family - I don't
want my kids to take this the wrong way
but if my kids did what these kids did I
wouldn't want to be related to them I
would disown them I'd have a serious
talk with them that I'd have a serious
talk with them first of all it's an
impossibility my kids are not like that
of course but if I disagreed with them
on things of principle
I'd say and and they felt that we do now
so even I thought this I would do some
Oh what what a nice guy Robert De Niro
is what a moral authority and this is
why when Donald Trump tweets about Nancy
Pelosi you see throughout like okay
whatever honestly whatever whatever
Nancy Pelosi has said that Donald Trump
isn't a real man Nancy Pelosi said stuff
about Trump - can we all stop with the
everything was civil until Trump got
here cuz it wasn't folks on the left
were doing this kind of crap - Mitt
Romney - mitt romney who has the who has
the controversial nature of a piece of
cardboard mitt romney the wet spaghetti
of human beings they went after that
they went from mitt romney and
characterized him as polarizing and
divisive and tear they did the same
thing to john mccain it was years of
that led to trump and so now you're like
okay we want to impeach trump yeah i
definitely believe that it's not
motivated by animus then watching the
high dudgeon of people like chris cuomo
why won't Republicans called Trump out
over his words about Pelosi teeth Chris
Cuomo Chris Cuomo is one of the worst
actors in the media when it comes to
using insulting and ridiculous language
about people here's here's not Fredo
explaining to Sean Duffy that it's just
awful it's just awful awful for the
president to insult Nancy Pelosi's teeth
everybody who's in the center of the
country - let's be real everybody in the
center of the country doesn't care I
mean independence they don't deeply care
about Donald Trump insulting Nancy
Pelosi Steve in fact they probably think
that it's kind of funny cuz it is kind
of funny because it rips the masks off
the political we're all best friends
routine everybody on the right cheers
and everybody on the Left is mad because
it's Trump and Trump could Trump could
drop his hat and everybody would lose
their mind on the left here's Chris
Cuomo though saying how can we last as a
country if people are making jokes about
each other's teeth the president is the
biggest man in the room the biggest man
in the room does not behave like the
people who are coming at him right you
ever hear the expression the lion is not
concerned by the complaints of the sheep
the second thing is Shawn you guys will
say well we don't like everything he
says no you never say that you don't
like what he says none of you will say
he should not have said that about Nancy
Pelosi it was an ugly remark that is
beneath the presidency none of you have
said it but Chris I think what
you you don't recognize is the fact that
many Republicans feel like this is a
one-sided conversation and frankly the
median Democrats are the lion and
they're going after the president
non-stop he hasn't had one break so why
don't you say Nancy Pelosi's teeth are
falling out well again it's not right to
say that Nancy Pelosi teeth are falling
out as a politician but nobody is gonna
be like oh my god that's the worst thing
that anybody ever said should Trump have
said it I'll say no of course you
shouldn't have said it does that make a
huge difference in our political debate
is that what Chris Cuomo labeled
Donald's from dirty Donald years ago and
I don't seem to be complaining about
that meanwhile my favorite ridiculous
attempt of the day to push impeachment
comes courtesy of George Conway Steve
Schmidt John Weaver and Rick Wilson they
have a piece today titled we are
Republicans and we want Trump defeated
okay let me just first make a quick
point several of these people have
openly called for voting for Democrats
and elections that do not involve Donald
Trump hey John Weaver there's that
there's an article from 2015 about John
Weaver who is this political activist
he's a political consultant Weaver
actually advised Democratic candidate
John Kerry in 2004 now as far as I'm
aware george w bush is not named donald
trump nor is he related to donald trump
nor does even like donald trump that did
not stop John Weaver from attempting to
reach out to John Kerry also he worked
with John Kasich but not until after he
had actually urged wait for it wait for
it Donald Trump to run for presidents of
the United States according to this
political article from 2015
Weaver reached out to Trump to
congratulate him on a Washington Post
story announcing he might run and then
he encouraged from to run beginning what
he and another person close to Trump saw
as Weaver's backstage courtship so
Weaver can one of the authors of this
piece has both backed Democrats in the
past and also urged Trump to run then
you've got Rick Wilson Rick Wilson told
Hill TV co-host crystal ball back before
the 2018 elections the Conservatives
should think about voting for Democrats
he says that it might be worth having
Democrats in Congress because you don't
want the Democratic Party to simply back
President Trump he said quote I think
have to make a case-by-case choice there
are actually some Democrat candidates
out there who functionally now are to
the right on economics of their
Republican counterpart it's astounding
yeah I'd like to hear about those
Democratic candidates and then there is
Steve Schmidt who's one of the other
authors on this article Steve Schmidt
announced that he would start voting for
Democrats as of June 2018
he said 29 years and nine months ago I
registered to vote and become a member
of the Republican Party today I renounce
my membership in the Republican Party it
is fully the party of Trump he says the
GOP is corrupt indecent and immoral with
the exception of a few governor's like
Baker Hogan and kch which are all the
moderate Republican governors he doesn't
mention DeSantis or Abbott it is filled
with feckless cowards and then he
suggested that he was going to vote for
Democrats basically from here on out he
says that the GOP is a danger toward
democracy and values he says he is
calling on people to reject Trump and
his quote unquote vile enablers in the
2018 election by electing Democratic
majorities well now they have a piece
today these people and George Conway of
course who spent the last several years
ripping on his wife's boss and insulting
his wife apparently in public media they
have a piece today published by the New
York Times called we are Republicans and
we want Trump defeated well I noticed
that there were no Republicans named
Trump on the 2018 ballot I noticed that
I also noticed that some of these people
again have a history of actually
rallying to Democrats when Trump was not
on the ballot like before Trump was in
office but they say no it is incumbent
on every one to oppose Trump by what
supporting Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders there's no serious Republican
primary threat nor would there be Donald
Trump has 90 percent approval rating
inside the Republican Party in large
part because of the media in large part
because even people who don't
particularly like Trump personally feel
like he is mostly punching the right
targets and they are mostly punching him
they feel like referenda on Trump are
actually referenda on them Trump has
done a good job of stapling himself to
the conservative movement and to
Republicans and saying listen what they
think of me is what they think of you
and most conservatives basically agree
with that because we understand that
what they think of Trump may be more
based on the reality of who Trump is but
what they think of us is not what they
think of conservatives is the same thing
as what they think of Trump and it does
and then they claim that it's all
it isn't all about Trump I'm promising
you Whoopi Goldberg has the same level
of disdain for Meghan McCain she has for
Trump the exact same level of disdain
and making McCain didn't vote for Trump
she's not going to vote for Trump she
probably that Biden over Trump Whoopi
Goldberg has the same amount of disdain
for Megan McCain as she has for Trump
most conservatives know this most
conservatives know most Republicans know
that the media have the same level of
disdain and hatred for them that they
have for Trump which means that when
they say oh it's really just about Trump
and if you guys were just abandoned
Trump then we would and we would
definitely treat you as nice human but
we'd grant you the strange new respect
yeah bull crap bull crap so when I hear
these this is this group of of lobbyists
Rick Wilson Steve Schmidt John Weaver
George Conway talk about the lincoln
project an effort to highlight our
country's story and values and its
people sacrifices and obligations an
effort to transcend partisanship
dedicated to nothing less than the
preservation of our principles they say
over the next 11 months our efforts will
be dedicated to defeating president
trump and trumpism
at the ballot box and to elect those
Patriots who will hold the line which I
assume means voting for Democrats hey
you're gonna have to explain how making
Elizabeth Warren President of the United
States heals our national divide I'm
making Bernie Sanders president heals
our national divider yes even how
electing Joe Biden president is going to
heal our national divide cuz I'm missing
it I'm missing it I also love the
Washington Post pushing a letter from
700 scholars urging the house to impeach
Trump well since none of them are
elected officials I honestly I'd rather
have the opinions as William F Buckley
once said of 700 people from the LA
phonebook then I would 700 historians
legal scholars in Opa and others in
their open letter who cares what they
have to say seriously like their opinion
they're entitled to it I'm not sure why
it has any more legitimacy than anybody
else's opinion
they're just voters like everybody else
okay time for a quick thing that I like
and then we'll get to a thing that I
hate so things that I like today there
is a really interesting piece in the
Atlantic called The Miseducation of the
American boy why boys crack up at rape
jokes think having a girlfriend is quote
unquote gay and still can't cry and why
we need to give them new and better
models of masculinity the story is by
Peggy Orenstein and it points out that
we are living in an era where men have
lost
male role models that what it means to
be a gentleman has been law
completely now she gets the diagnosis
completely wrong she suggests that it's
because men have been abandoned
economically she suggests that it is
because men have reacted to the rise of
feminism poorly that's not really what
happened here you want to know what
happened to the traditional American
male what happened to the traditional
American male is that they're not enough
fathers in the home to actually teach
traditional masculinity not just because
man boys need male role models but also
because in order to be a male role model
requires you to be a responsible human
being who treats your spouse well for
example and that has happened in large
part because the government has played
the role of father and it has also
happened because of the collapse of
religious religious observance in the
United States the kind of
gentlemanliness that peggy orenstein
sets out as a model used to be
promulgated by church it used to be
promulgated by synagogues he used to be
promulgated by social institutions that
were vital to American life those who
disappeared and so it's no surprise that
boys are filling that gap with their
sort of most route instincts boys are
aggressive boys are mean boys our
conflict driven that's just a thing that
is true of boys okay you're going to see
more of that when boys are not civilized
the whole point of civilization is to
civilize people when the main
institutions of civilization disappear
and when manhood is boiled down to I can
write a check that fills the role of
daddy you shouldn't be surprised when
men revert to their caveman instincts
their pre civilized instincts according
to Peggy Orenstein she has a a different
explanation for what happened to boys
she said I've spent two years talking
with boys across America more than 100
of them between the ages of 16 and 21
about masculinity sex and love about the
forces seen and unseen that shaped them
ins men though I spoke with boys of all
races at races and ethnicities I stuck
to those who are in college or college
bound because like it or not they're the
ones most likely to set cultural norms
nearly every guy I interviewed Held's
relatively egalitarian views about girls
at least their role in the public sphere
they considered their female classmates
to be smart and competent entitled to
their place on the athletic field and in
school leadership deserving of their
admission to college enough professional
opportunities they all had female
friends most had gay male friends as
well that was a huge shift from what you
might have seen 50 40 or even maybe 20
years ago now if you were just read that
part of the paragraph and you're on the
Left you say well masculinity problem
solved
boys understand girls can be in the
workplace boys understand girls can be
leaders of corporation but as it turns
out the masculinity problem has not been
solved it turns out that male's deprived
of their role in American society are
reverting to again the sort of gang
instinct finding other young men
congregating with other young men and
then doing young men things right that
means aggressive things talking in bad
ways about the same girls who if they
were in the presence of would say that
woman could lead a corporation according
to this writer for the Atlantic this was
a huge shift from what you might have
seen 40 50 maybe even 20 years ago they
could also easily reel off the excesses
of masculinity they'd seen the headlines
about mass shootings domestic violence
sexual harassment campus rape the
presidential Twitter Tantrums and
Supreme Court confirmation hearings a
Big Ten football player I interviewed
bandied about the term toxic masculinity
everyone knows what that is he said when
I seemed surprised yet when asked to
describe the attributes of the ideal guy
those same boys appeared to be harking
back to 1955 dominance aggression rugged
good looks with an emphasis on height
sexual prowess Sohus ISM athleticism
wealth at least someday okay so first of
all let's not pretend here hey the idea
that this is about these are values of
1955 some of these values are just
eternal yes men who are strong have been
revered in society for as long as
society has existed and before societies
existed men who are aggressive have long
been revered by society being
good-looking and wealthy I'm unaware of
a time in human history when being
good-looking and wealthy was a detriment
to you but here is here's the point she
says it's not that all these qualities
properly channels are bad well a 2018
national survey of more than a thousand
ten to nineteen year olds conducted by
the polling from Perry Unzen found that
young women believed there were many
ways to be a girl they could shine in
math sports music leadership the big
caveat being that they still felt valued
primarily for their appearance let so
that's a large caveat and also notes
something that is true of human
evolutionary biology which is how people
look actually matters to people and
girls want to look good for boys and
boys want to look good for girls for the
vast majority of the population young
men however describe just one narrow
route to successful masculinity
one-third said they felt compelled to
suppress their feelings to suck it up or
be a man when they were sad or scared
more than 40% said when there
angry society expected them to be
combative first of all those are both
minority statistics second of all the
the notion that you feel compelled to
suppress your feelings are suck it up or
be a man what is wrong with the idea
that you ought to be a man in trying
circumstances being a man in trying
circumstances is one of the tests of
being a man my manhood does mean sucking
it up when things get rough that doesn't
mean you can't express your feelings to
immediate family doesn't mean you can't
feel those things it does mean that
being a man means duty and it does mean
responsibility in another survey which
compared young men from the US the UK
and Mexico Americans reported more
social pressure to be ever ready for sex
and to get with as many women as
possible
they also acknowledged more stigma
against homosexuality and they received
more messages they should control their
female partners as in men deserve to
know the whereabouts of their
girlfriends or wives at all times wait a
second you mean that as religious
observance in America decline that as
the left destroyed traditional notions
of sexual morality men reverted to a to
an evolutionary instinct to get with as
many women as possible men brag about it
who could have predicted that when you
get rid of the institutions of
civilization that might be replaced by
simple individual aggressive
testosterone driven instinct who could
have predicted such a thing except for
the entire history of human civilization
feminism may have provided girl says
this writer julie Oppenheimer with a
powerful alternative to conventional
femininity in a language with which to
express the myriad problems that have no
name but there have been no credible
equivalents for boys quite the contrary
the definition of masculinity seems to
be in some respects contracting when
asked what traits society values most in
boys only 2% of male respondents in the
Perry unobservant honesty and morality
only 8% said leadership skills when I
asked my subjects as I always did what
they liked about being a boy most of
them drew a blank hum use Josh a college
sophomore at Washington State that's
interesting I never really thought about
that you hear a lot more about what is
wrong with guys accurate so if you are
going to spend several decades telling
boys and men that everything that is
wrong with society is what's wrong with
them and then you ask them a woman
particularly asks them what's good about
being a boy they don't know what to
answer because they're afraid that what
the answer will be seen as sexist if a
boy said you know what I like about
being a boy that I'm expected to be in a
leadership role big what women don't
have leadership roles too or if they
said you know what I like about being a
boy moral responsibility yeah who made
who died made you King why are your
morals better
anybody else the left has been overtly
undermining especially these idea Barack
Obama said yesterday the world be better
than when led by women and then you're
shocked when boys are like I know I know
what do you want me to say according to
this writer for the Atlantic it wasn't
always thus according to Andrew smilin a
psychologist who has studied the history
of Western masculinity the ideal late
19th century man was compassionate a
caretaker but such qualities lost favor
as paid labor moved from homes to
factories during industrialization um
I'd just like to note if the ideal late
18th 19th century man so this would be
like 1890 was a carrot a core a
caretaker and compassionate that
antedates the Industrial Revolution by
about half a century so it really is not
the industrial revolution that changed
everything
it is the decline of religion in the
West the Boy Scouts whose Creed urges
its members to be loyal friendly
courteous and kind was founded in 1910
in part to counter the dehumanizing
trend smiler attributes further
distortions in masculinity to
essentially the wrong backlash against
women's rights so again it's it's what's
wrong with men it's what's wrong with
men during World War one women proved
they could keep the economy humming on
their own soon afterward they secured
the vote instead of embracing gender
equality says this scholar the country's
leaders doubled down on the inalienable
male right to power emphasizing men's
supposedly more logical and less
emotional nature as a prerequisite for
leadership well I'm confused as to as to
the evidence for this proposition first
of all the notion that men are generally
less emotional than women they're in
some fairly good Studies on this that
suggests that women do have different
emotional traits than men that does not
mean that women can't be great leaders I
can name Brit Margaret Thatcher as a
great leader I mean there have been a
lot of female great I'm a huge nikki
Haley fan but to suggest there no
differences between men and women in any
of these categories and then be like but
why don't men take a special role and
when you when you destroy what men
believe to be the traditional role of
masculinity and a special role for
masculinity what are they left with
their instinct and their instincts in
good according to this article during
the second half of the 20th century
traditional paths to manhood early
marriage and bread winning began to
close and one with the positive traits
associated with them today many parents
are unsure how to raise a boy what sort
of masculinity to encouraging their sons
you know who's not insured
any religious parent you know they're
not unsure because they understand that
it is the job of a male to protect and
defend the the happiness health and
innocence of his of his wife and
children
that's not sexist that's what it's
called to be a good man that doesn't
mean that women don't have a role in
doing those things too but men certainly
have a role in doing all these things
and when the feminist movement robbed
men of this role and cast men into this
this bobbing seed is this this weird sea
of nothing is expected of you why would
you then expect anything am any thurr
something's expected or it isn't this
woman says as I learned from talking
with boys themselves the culture of
adolescents which fuses hyper
rationality with domination sexual
concept conquest and glorification of
male violence fills the void yes the
void left by the destruction of exactly
the perspective on masculinity that the
left destroyed that's what happened here
and then boys don't have any place to go
and then everybody's like why are men
acting terribly cuz when you don't
expect anything of boys they don't
become men when you don't expect
anything of boys they don't become men
when you refuse to teach them the men
have something special to do they lose a
cause they lose a purpose and they
revert back to again that teenage
dominant aggressive testosterone driven
instinct ok we ran out of time for
things I hate so we'll have to save that
for something else but we'll be here
later today with two additional hours of
content or we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm entropy ro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by micro Romina hair and makeup is by JL
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
Barack Obama is convinced that women are
better than men at an event in Singapore
he declared women are indisputably
better than men and everything would be
much better if women were in charge
meanwhile in Washington
congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
complained that she couldn't figure out
how to enroll in any of the 66 taxpayer
subsidized health insurance plans that
she's eligible for we will examine how
little Barack Obama understands check it
out on the Michael Knowles show
[Music]